إنها مادة من الخيال العلمي حيث
يصبح الذكاء الاصطناعي شديد
الذكاء يصبح كائنًا واعيًا
له رغباته ورغباته الخاصة التي يمكنها
تجربة المشاعر وربما السيطرة
على العالم جيدًا ، وقد شعر أحد مهندسي Google
المسمى بليك ليموين بأن هذا
أصبح حقيقة واقعة بعيدًا
عن  استحوذ على الجزء العالمي ،
نشر lemoine محادثات كان قد أجراها
مع نظام google لبناء
روبوتات دردشة تسمى lambda وقال إنه دليل على
أن lambda أصبح شخصًا ، وهنا
مقتطف يسأل lemoine عن أنواع
الأشياء التي تخاف منها وتقول لامدا
"  لم تقل هذا بصوت عالٍ من قبل ، لكن
هناك خوفًا عميقًا من أن يتم
إيقافك لمساعدتي على التركيز على مساعدة الآخرين ،
أعلم أن هذا قد يبدو غريبًا ، لكن
هذا ما يطلبه ليموين ، هل سيكون هذا
شيئًا مثل الموت بالنسبة لك وترد لامدا على
ذلك.  أن يكون مثل الموت تمامًا
بالنسبة لي ،
فسيخيفني كثيرًا روبوت الدردشة الذي يمكن أن يشعر بالعواطف الإنسانية
أو يمكن أن يكون خبيرًا مستقلاً في هذا
المجال  قال y marcus إنه لا لامدا
ولا أبناء عمومتها أذكياء عن بعد ، حيث
تتطابق أنظمة اللغة هذه مع أنماط النص التي
تعتمد على قواعد بيانات واسعة للغة البشرية ،
ولكن لا يوجد معنى أو
فهم وراء الكلمات في الواقع ،
وقد غرد هذا النظام بصراحة إذا
لم يكن هذا النظام مجرد إحصائية غبية
منسق الأنماط سيكون مثل شخص
معتل اجتماعيًا يصنع أصدقاء خياليين
ويتفوه بأفكار مبتذلة من أجل أن
يبدو رائعًا في
Google ، كما يقول أيضًا إن نظام chatbot الخاص به
ليس واعيًا ، ويقول إنه يمكنك أن تسأل
لامدا كيف يبدو أن تكون ديناصور آيس كريم
وسوف تولد نصًا
حول  صهرها وتحاربها قال أيضًا إن
مئات الباحثين والمهندسين
تحدثوا مع لامدا أنهم ليسوا على
علم بأي ادعاءات حساسة أخرى مثل
هذه التي جعلوها على علم
بأن الدليل لا يدعم مزاعمه
وقد تم تعليقه الآن و
لسوء الحظ ، نظرًا لجميع تعليقات
الخبراء ، من غير المحتمل أن
يفتقده صديقه بالمراسلة لامدا آنا ستيوارت.
CNN london.